how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
everything marvel's cinematic universe
things are getting super exciting as
phase 4 has officially started we got
the third episode for
wanda vision just a couple of days ago
and we have so many
exciting future marvel projects that
have already been announced by marvel
studios themselves such as spider-man
homecoming 3 which as of right now
remains
titleist hopefully that changes soon
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness the fantastic four
black panther 2 and plenty of other
awesome shows and
movies coming very soon i mentioned
these specific titles because i do
believe
that all of these multiverse films will
eventually lead to the introduction and
mcu debut of victor von doom aka dr
doom we have some recent reports that
we'll get into stating that doctor doom
may be coming to the mcu a lot sooner
than we thought and i personally think
that juan division is going to set up
doctor doom in a very big way and then
doctor strange 2 as well could be his
first official debut
in the marvel cinematic universe before
going on to his own
movie which could be a main role in
black panther 2. so in this video i will
break down how i think one division will
set up dr doom how he'll debut
in doctor strange 2. his connection of
course to the fantastic four which has
been officially announced and how the
fantastic four could debut in ant-man 3
quantum mania all leading up to black
panther 2 where doom could be a main
character and of course the battle
between the fantastic
four and doom himself so let's start out
with one division and how i think
doctor doom is definitely going to be
set up in future episodes
now the first few episodes of one
division haven't really dove into
the witchcraft side of it yet yes wanda
aka the scarlet witch is using reality
warping powers but the scarlet witch per
se
hasn't exactly been seen yet now for
those who may not know
dr doon is very heavily tied to
witchcraft and
mephisto dr doom is one of the greatest
sorcerers that the marvel universe has
ever seen but it all starts with his
mother
cynthia von doom who i think we actually
might see
in the one division series and mephisto
some time ago we got some leaked photos
for the one division series
that showed a bunch of witches among
those was the nosy neighbor agnes
in a full witch attire which basically
confirms that she is indeed agatha
harkness which we really didn't have any
doubts about now agatha herself is an
extremely powerful witch who can live
for a very long time
key point being she was alive during the
salem witch trials but in these photos i
actually think that one of these people
could be cynthia von doom the mother of
doctor doom
and this would be a great way for marvel
to connect agatha harkness
to cynthia von doom especially since i
believe that agatha harkness in the one
division series
is working for the demon mephisto now
cynthia was born into a remaining clan
in latveria she married warner von doom
and together they had their son
victor cynthia was learned and tutored
in magic and the dark arts
communicating with demons and casting
spells and cynthia's people faced
constant persecution at the hands of the
baron
and his men and in an effort to fight
back and protect her people she made a
deal with the demon mephisto
promising him her soul in return for
power so cynthia went and started to
kill the baron's men but unbeknownst to
her
the magic she was using also killed
every child in the village which was a
part of mephisto's plan the whole entire
time
of course she was horrified at what she
did and she renounced her powers but
then she died
due to one of the guardsmen stabbing her
dying in her husband's arm she made him
promise that victor would never walk the
same path as her
when she died her soul was trapped in
mephisto's realm to be tortured for all
eternity fast forward to the future and
now a grown-up
victor von doom and king of latveria
being very learned in the mystic arts
every mid-summer's eve when the barriers
between earth and the other realms were
particularly thin
he challenged mephisto and his forces
for a chance to free his mother's soul
but he never won he could never defeat
mephisto on his own
now since one division is seemingly
introducing this demon mephisto
and as we learned at the very end of
episode 3 of one division
this does take place during the actual
modern time in the mcu
most likely in the year 2023 or 2024
based off of when avengers end game
happened this means that doctor doom is
most likely an adult which means his
mother has already been captured by
mephisto and her soul is in mephisto's
realm so the coming of mephisto and
wanda vision and the introduction of
actual witches in the show sets up
doctor doom and his mother
cynthia von doom not to mention several
months ago there was a report that said
we will see
doomstat in one division doomstat is the
capital of latveria and where dr doom
was born
but this isn't the only setup that
doctor doom is going to have we know
that one division is going to tie
directly into doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness
wanda could even be the villain at least
for some time she won't be the main
villain but she might be a villain at
first but mephisto is still going to be
around during doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness in fact he's
probably going to be one of the main big
bads of not only phase 4 but also
possibly phase 5.
now doctor strange of course has a lot
of ties to mephisto but
doctor strange and dr doom together have
big ties with mephisto as a group as i
mentioned dr doom could never defeat
mephisto's forces to get his mother's
soul back
until he won a favor from doctor strange
and he used that favor to ask him to
help retrieve his mother's soul
the two of them battled their way
through mephisto's demons until
ultimately finding him
in which victor von doom at that time
made a deal with mephisto to give him
doctor strange in return for his
mother's freedom
mephisto agreed and doom captured doctor
strange and gave him to mephisto
however when his mother learned the
price that victor had to pay for her
soul she rejected him denouncing him as
a traitor and then her soul was once
again trapped by mephisto however
this was actually a trap by dr doom and
doctor strange all along victor had
provided doctor strange with a device to
free himself from his bonds
allowing him to escape in which doctor
strange and dr doom continued to fight
mephisto and during this battle mephisto
accidentally ended up freeing the soul
of cynthia von doom
and after rejecting her son's attempted
rescue she had earned her redemption so
her soul was free to go on to a better
afterlife so doctor strange and dr doom
had a full-on
battle with mephisto and it looks like
mephisto is going to tie into heavily
into one division and then
in doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness and as i mentioned since victor
von doom is most likely an adult in the
marvel cinematic universe at this point
his mother is most likely already
captured and kept in the hell dimension
where mephisto is
and kevin feige the president of marvel
studios did say that there is going to
be a mystery character in doctor strange
too and all he told us about the
character
is that it's somebody that marvel has
always wanted to use and
that audiences won't be expecting their
debut
well marvel couldn't actually use dr
doom in the past due to the fox rights
so doctor doom could very well be
somebody that marvel has always wanted
to use
but couldn't and since doctor doom is so
heavily tied to the fantastic four
i don't think any of the fans are
expecting him to debut
in doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness except for me because i made
this theory
so it is possible that we could see
doctor doom debut in the marvel
cinematic universe and doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness since
everything is going to be
crazy in that movie now ultimately if
this would happen it's just going to be
a cameo
a setup we will most likely see doctor
doom as a main villain in black panther
2.
this is not confirmed yet but in a
couple of different reports from
fandomwire and charles murphy at
murphysmultiverse.com
they have stated that doctor doom is
going to be a villain in black panther 2
and we could be seeing the story of doom
war
now do-more is a story that could fit
quite well into black panther 2.
t'challa has lost the throne of wakanda
but storm
who is his wife at the time is on trial
for practicing
witchcraft which has a connection to
doctor doom meanwhile
doctor doom is attempting to crack into
the vault in wakanda that contains
vibranium the reason that he wants the
vibranium is a secret that nobody else
knows about and that is that it can
amplify
mystical energies and its effects are
infinite with the vibranium it would
essentially make
doctor doom unstoppable and this is a
storyline that we could see in black
panther 2 and perhaps he wants that
vibranium so he can go and fight
mephisto since he fails multiple times
to get his mother's soul back perhaps he
thinks the vibranium will help him
finally defeat the demon now of course
this is going to be a
huge story and the debut of dr doom is
going to be absolutely insane and it
looks like marvel studios
may not want to make doom just a
fantastic four villain because typically
that is who he is associated with
after all in every single live-action
fantastic four movie we've had
dr doom has been in it so making him a
villain that is not connected to the
fantastic four at first could actually
be a really good idea but of course we
know that eventually he will become
the villain for the fantastic four in
the marvel cinematic universe and then
ultimately i think he will go on to
become
god emperor doom but that will be way
down the line when the secret war story
finally comes to light
now the fantastic four are most likely
going to debut in ant-man 3 before their
own solo film
they might mention dr doom and ant-man 3
but i think in the actual movie is when
they're going to take on doom perhaps
with the help of some other heroes
because i think from the very start in
one division they are setting up doom to
be
a main big bad of the marvel cinematic
universe
if i hear more about doctor doom's debut
i will be sure to let you know so be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest mcu news be sure to
let me know what you think about this
video in the comments down below don't
forget to like the video and for live
updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof